walk him to this video let's see I
caricom and the f3 line the fantasy
variation yeah this is an interesting
interesting one and I forgot as usual
what I recommend it Queen B 6 I remember
that Queen B 6 was the move but but the
details hmm pack of Bishop c5 934 hmm
yeah it seems to head seems to be a a
well-known line as this guy's playing
everything instantly of course I don't
know it all I forgot it the check if I
check here King e2 it's probably
pointless yeah probably it is pointless
Jack came came so huh before
b5 can I threaten be five if I drop back
I can take take and b5 is probably
probably nonsense and take and take a
form okay let's not take too long I mean
at least have spotters castling rights
and if I was hanging
hmm yeah he's got the two bishops and
he's got a potentially very strong dark
squared Bishop should be three and so on
plane now let's develop you know I need
to go all the way back
yeah I don't mind the point so much what
I do mind is hmm it's not so terrible I
thought Queen d6 while the problem but I
can take a night at five this isn't this
isn't a big deal and if it takes before
then as development is really lagging
don't forget that he's got this funky
rukon g1 so we cannot easily play thats
a bishop somewhere and castle yeah i'm
not sure but i don't want to for more
beer behind on the clock fall behind on
the clock Union wall so this is a
correct sentence I don't know and 96 I
play 95 so this isn't a problem yeah
this is some serious move i wonder if i
should play a 505 and getting young a 5s
got to think the idea is to take and
play night f5 to deform and in the
process i also activate the rook
possibly yeah take
night a 696 is actually also an idea it
gains a temple on before interesting I
mean interesting is that is not moving
have a look at something I don't know
okay but this looks nice winning a
temple and the lights didn't have
anything greater do 1d seven so dr. look
decent an IG five has in fact um
normally move okay let's go here maybe
you can play Knight f6 check Knight f6
check hmm I didn't think about that
ok so here Knight d4 is this too much
probably let's let's let's let's cover
first 94 is still in the air and I've
got Queen B 6 which is also something to
consider attacking the rook and
attacking the beef or pawn this can be a
very strong actually Bishop c4 I just I
just recognized Oh be 5 p-5 should I
plane 84 or not hmm I go here what are
you doing rook rook hangs
long castles hmm looks a completely
wacky but maybe it's it's the way to go
Queen B 6 also had the idea to prepare
night c 5 night c 5 193 even 93 queen
bee three
well talk about the difficult position
very hard to to figure out what's going
on but I think this is okay if you place
the Queen I can take on g2 also just
check just checking and if he moves the
King I've got Bishop g4 also with the
check so I win really lots of time ok on
f2 I on f7 unders is of course a problem
hi this is hanging
okay let's give this check if you they
can just take it what am i doing laughs
he can just take it he didn't mm-hmm I
thought 95 but I completely forgot that
there's also a sick saying so check if
this check first what a silly game
I can actually check here let's still
have seven hanging ok let's let's just
do that if he takes a six I just I just
recapture and hope on the eighth on the
beef allium squinty for yeah it's just a
total mess probably lost for black with
the perfect play
hmm
no it's really difficult to to come up
with a move but at the moment I'm not
threatening a rugby eight but probably
threatening this move yeah should I
should I take I'll behead I will be
edwins the Queen yeah I should win the
Queen this is sound check probably the
best way to go about it ok so is there
made somewhere mate mate mate like
looked it to time but I know that I made
check Oh check
I hope I'm not getting waited somehow
white for that one time should do you
want or something wow it's no made or
not white actually wins in this position
position with 96 okay but it's not a
comp Bishop takes and rookie one Wow
yeah okay it's even it's just material
up by the at the moment yeah just a
completely wacky game the ante a was
winning here I thought I was actually
winning after I got the queen but he's
got so much material so after Bishop
takes I probably should have recaptured
it is some attack it's not like it's
nothing but now okay yeah just a just a
complete mess um I cafergot theory here
its own this line with queen bee 685 is
actually interesting but Knight c3 e5 I
think if I was right takes Bishop c5 hmm
yeah I don't know the computer wants to
go the wants to go live at this is
strange hey yeah i don't know i would
need to look it up actually in a
database or something alright thanks for
watching